hey what's up folks were live from petty
Arcade Expo east right here in Boston
one of the biggest boots they have on
the show floor is Bethesda's where
they're showing off not only evil within
but also Wolfenstein new order and Chris
waters you played it for an hour and a
half today i sat down and played wolfy
times for really a lot I don't know I
just like to call that it's stupid but
it's like the game has kind of has this
silly sensibility to it like Matt 60
there it's a laugh riot there enslaving
the world you know what I mean this what
the Sun games have always had like it
sort of balanced that like this is a
dark time and you are doing action hero
stuff but they're still like I'm gonna
kick some burgers like attitude like a
little swagger to it and that's one of
the things that I like a lot about the
game another and I played a big chunk of
it the even though it's the attitude
kind of feels all over the place in some
ways in other ways it's just like great
melange of personalities like you've got
bj blaskowitz being a badass being a
ridiculous action hero you know with
like he's gonna pick up a chain saw an
awesome dudes head off but it says he
needs splatter protection so you carry
the right to pick the rich chainsaw
right up pretty good but then you have
you know the emotional stuff like war is
messed up and like Eli cares about these
people he's with in like some messed up
stuff happens and then you've got just a
pure joy of private river I remember
Brett so we're base is this set if you
played the start of the game yes so
there's not the stuff in London no it's
not in London I don't want to give away
too much about how the game begins but
it's well it's sort of a Normandy esque
invasion okay and that's the prologue
and then after the prologue it shifts to
a different setting which I didn't play
too far beyond the prologue but you know
I started off their five difficulty
levels and in Wolfenstein fashion they
go from like smiley happy playing to
like ooh my eyes are bleeding and half
of my skull is showing like super hard
so I played on the fourth of five
difficulty levels and after a while is
fighting through these trenches fighting
my way along a kind of
felt like I was like in a good groove so
I kicked it up and then it was then it
was interesting then it wasn't just like
going through the motions like making a
few good head shots it was like it was
harder and you know people talked about
it being harder and this sort of
old-school sensibility of shooters but
what got me was how because it was hard
I had to change the way i was playing in
like pay attention to my armor and help
stats yeah and like you know actually
you know wait behind cover actually pop
out actually search for health stuff and
make sure I was at a good spot because
like on that difficulty level if your
clip isn't full and you're exposed
trying to like reload it you're gonna
dock so where does this lie in the sort
of like the moment moment action where
does it lie on the sort of tactical
first-person shooter and then another
skate you've got like old-school quake
and more 3d yeah is it is it mostly like
kind of as crazy Serious Sam type
software just run around blowing stuff
or it's definitely not as crazy as
serious and which is like a very like
fast sprint all the time yeah but they
do encourage you to move a lot and
that's got its got a sprint and it's got
this slide maneuver and then it sort of
has like a free-form cover thing where
you pull the shoulder button and like
can lean up for lean under can lean out
to the side like you know to sort of to
pop around cover and stuff like that but
they want you on the move Nazis are
aggressive they'll flush you out if
you're just trying to like stay behind
cover reload and take potshots it's not
really gonna fly okay and the other
thing is that whenever you talk about
this game whenever I've heard other
people play this game and talk about it
they keep bringing up the like
interesting personalities are in this
game even from the trainer where you see
this like referee like shooting a player
like this game seems to have a good
attitude going on uh-huh does it work is
it entertaining as if funny I like it so
there's a lot of different personality
stuff you know you've got that sort of
the American soldiers were like dude
we're
to get through this war cliche more
cliche joke joke not but then you know
you've got the Nazi villains yeah are
like proper villain like this guy
general death's-head they've been
talking about a bunch lately right there
and like he's got this face it kind of
looks skeletal like his it's scarred so
his lips are tight and like there's just
one scene where you're like gets like
this door closes behind you or you're in
this incinerator and we turn around and
like all of a sudden there's his face
like creeped me out I like I but I was
excited by it because it's more exciting
when you have an enemy that you'd like
well what get I hate you you do creepy
and then like he's moving around he has
like a little bit of Gollum to him well
super super creepy dude and so like
that's happening or then you know you're
you're sort of reminiscing or your your
your meeting with resistance people or
your remanent like Vijay is doing this
like reminiscent about how things used
to be and how they are like there's just
a lot of personality to it and that's
something that like a shooter campaign
doesn't necessarily have a lot like we
don't see a lot of personality campaigns
like that you know we see some that are
you know you mentioned Bulletstorm and
that certainly has personality but it's
a very specific kind yeah I think I feel
like Wolfenstein castanet a little bit
broader okay it's hard to sort of tell
if it's gonna all come together well but
so far so good and I really enjoyed my
hour and a half of it for sure also I'm
excited after he talked about it as well
yeah and if you folks want to know more
about it there's an in-depth preview on
the site from Dan Hines in Australia he
played the same demo I did but he wrote
a lot more about some different systems
some secrets that he found and sort of
how it stacks up versus old-school
Wolfenstein play which he loves so be
sure to check that one out and stay
tuned for more from pax east it's good
time
you